welcome today we're going to show you how to
start keto correctly and this is for beginners
what are we trying to do we're trying to switch
what your body is running on as far as fuel-wise
so we want to switch from burning sugar fuel to
fat fuel there's this one hormone called insulin
which is the key to determine whether you're going
to burn fat or burn sugar so you want to keep it
low to burn fat when it goes higher your body
will burn sugar very simply lower your carbs
and eat less meals that's different than
lowering your calories now by eating less meals
you are going to lower your calories but that's
not the goal you could actually eat larger meals
just not as frequent why is it a good idea to
eat less frequent meals because every time you
eat you trigger insulin every time you eat carbs
you trigger insulin so we're just trying to lower
this insulin the combination between these two
are very very powerful so what are you going to
eat in a meal well first thing you have to eat
low carb so you want to cut down all your carbs
that includes sugar and i'm talking about honey
agave nectar brown sugar white sugar date sugar
all sugar you can replace it in various
recipes with what's called sugar alcohols
i put some links down below of examples of
that so you can learn about that but there's
these sweet alternative sugar sources that
you can use so that means that when you go
buy food you have to start reading the labels
and looking at the sugar content you want it
as close to zero as possible you want to
avoid fruit except for berries there's
three berries raspberries strawberries and
blackberries you can have those in small amounts
but no other fruit especially apples grains like
wheat flour that they make breads pasta cereal
crackers biscuits you want to avoid that but
guess what there's a substitute there's a people
use almond flour to make all sorts of things from
pizza crust to bread to you name it so there's a
lot of recipes that you can use as an alternative
grain avoid starches like potatoes but guess what
there's all these recipes that you can make out of
cauliflower that is very similar to the starches
not identical but you can make things that are
very close to tasting like mashed potatoes you can
even make a cauliflower crust for your pizza it's
quite good now when i say cut out all the carbs
there's an exception vegetables in fact you want
to consume more vegetables at least seven cups you
know even more that could be salads or other types
of vegetables like bell peppers like cabbage like
broccoli kale brussels sprouts and at this level
that i'm teaching you you can even do carrots and
tomatoes beets don't worry about that you can have
those and the last point about vegetables is that
ideally if you eat them first it's going to be a
lot easier to consume seven cups than after you
have the protein and fat because this is going to
fill you up pretty fast so i always consume the
vegetable first now you can consume it at the same
time but just as a strategy to make sure you get
enough vegetables in your diet i like to consume
these first because very few people consume enough
vegetables and one last point vegetables provide
two things they provide food for your microbes
that then help your blood sugars and help give you
energy also they provide a lot of nutrients like
potassium and magnesium and even vitamin c because
what are we trying to do we're trying to do keto
correctly and by correctly i mean healthily okay
number two moderate protein not massive amounts
like in the atkins diet but moderate amounts
that could be depending on your size and
your metabolism and your age between three and
eight ounces maybe you're 18 years old and you
work out hardcore you're gonna need maybe more
protein so rather than have a little scale and
measure it just consume protein the size of the
palm of your hand maybe a little bit more a little
less okay just to kind of keep it really simple at
this level what type of protein different types of
meat fish chicken seafood eggs cheese unless you
have an allergy or any type of severe gut issue
nuts or nut butters also make sure that
you if you buy peanut butter or whatever
you read the ingredients to make sure it doesn't
have added sugar you don't want to add sugar to
any of these because sometimes when you have
like deli meats they have dextrose in there or
extra sugar if you're having bacon
they have extra sugar added you
preferably keep the sugar away from your protein
all right with the protein as far as the order of
when you eat it you just ate your vegetable
your salad now you start with your protein
the key with the protein is not to consume lean
protein or low fat protein try to consume protein
that has more fat why because that's going
to help your insulin levels when you consume
protein that's very low fat and lean as in like
powders especially like whey protein powder
you majorly increase insulin versus consuming
fattier meat or fattier fish or like brie cheese
which is has more fat so that's a really key
point about protein all right the third thing
is that you're on a higher fat diet now when we
talk about higher fats mainly we're talking about
the calories there's more than twice as many
calories in fat than there is protein in carbs
so based on calories it would be a higher fat diet
so i'm not going to say anything more to confuse
you on that point but realize that when you're
consuming the protein guess what you're consuming
a lot of the fat in your diet already because
protein always comes with fat but you may add
some additional fats let's say some avocado
butter to cook your food in or let's say you
melt the butter on your vegetables which is a good
idea because the veggies have certain fat soluble
natural chemicals in there that are good for you
even antioxidants they're called phytonutrients
and adding oil to your salad whether it's
olive oil or butter over your vegetables
will help you extract those nutrients out of that
meal that's why it's good to combine these things
right here olives or olive oil is very very good
coconut oil is actually also pretty good and of
course some of these are in the fat category like
nuts for example or half fat and half protein
a little bit of carb cheese is protein and fat
eggs are protein and fat so a lot of these are fat
too so both of these are kind of a combination but
if you're starting keto a lot of times people add
maybe some nuts or cheese after the meal to be
more satisfied so that's something that they do
and so that's why i said eat this third but of
course it could be within the meal now there's
certain fats you definitely want to avoid
soy oil corn oil canola oil cottonseed oil
even the safflower oil the sunflower oil i would
be careful about consuming too much of those
these are gmo they have chemicals in them but
the problem is they're highly inflammatory even
though it's a fat it's the wrong type of fat that
you want in your body and you probably see these
in salad dressings and many different products
like mayonnaise in there so you're going to have
to kind of start reading labels and really get
picky on certain things that you're going to be
buying so we talked about generally what to
eat but we also want to talk about eating less
meals right less frequent meals we're going
to do intermittent fasting we're going to
combine both of these together to really take that
insulin and bring it down to our normal level so
here's the rule of thumb don't eat unless
you are hungry now let me define hungry
because sometimes you might get a little
bit of hunger but you still feel strong
uh you still feel fine your mood is good we'll
try to push through that okay there's also a
difference between hunger and also like a habit
people have like a habit of eating all the time
even when they're not hungry because they feel
that they're not as full as maybe they should be
so you don't have to be full all the time we're
talking about hungry and a true hunger is like wow
i feel like i really need to eat i feel a little
bit weaker i feel a little shaky i'm starting
to notice i'm a little bit more irritable okay
that is what we're talking about not some little
temporary hunger number two ideally you want
to skip the breakfast you can do this on a
gradual level where you keep pushing your
breakfast later and later and later or just
cut it right out and just skip breakfast instead
have your coffee with a little butter in it a
tablespoon of butter and or mct oil which will
help you greatly in making ketones which is very
therapeutic to your brain and it'll satisfy you so
as you're trying to transition into the state of
ketosis which you're burning fat because ketones
are a byproduct of burning fat if you add mct oil
that will give you ketones right away and it'll
make the transition a little more comfortable
especially with your cognitive function so this is
a good idea and if you did this coffee with this
these two fats it's going to be very easy to
skip breakfast also i want to note that about
8 am in the morning is when you have this
hormonal shift with cortisol might go up and
you may find a temporary about a half hour kind
of a a sense like i i'm ready to eat something
it's the cortisol it's a hormonal shift and it can
increase your appetite just ignore that and push
through that okay so we're skipping our breakfast
at this point number three very importantly do not
snack through the day that little snack
even though it's low amount of calories
will make you hungry eating stimulates hunger
especially if it's in the form of a snack
so just cut out all snacking it's very very
important if you get the temptation the snack
just realize that you didn't consume enough fat
at the last meal so the next meal add more fat
to the diet so you can go easily from one
meal to the next so it's important to add
more fat to go longer there's a lot of details
to fill in the blank but typically you can drink
water tea coffee anything without sugar you can
take your vitamins it's not going to be a problem
and again there's a lot of details that i'm
not covering but i'm just giving you the basics
so let's say your first meal is at noon okay
you eat your meal don't really worry at this
point about calories because we're not trying to
reduce calories all we're trying to do is have
that first meal make sure it fits what i said
in the last slide and then the second meal at
six so that gives you a six hour eating window
and 18-hour fast okay if you don't snack
which is huge this is going to allow you to see
a lot of benefits with this program so that is
the summary of how to do keto correctly before
you go if you have a question about a product
or you're new to keto and you want to know
how to begin keto or you're on keto and you
need a debug because it's not going as smooth i
have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the us hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help